you mentioned in Prior interviews for
your latest film fischeri that you were
looking for talented people but not
stars why is that the reason is not at
the peril of sounding not-so-humble I
would say that the star part has taken
care of because in my area where I come
from I'm what is called the star
material and I thought that's trouble
enough it don't need much more stars and
tantrums in the film and as far as this
one star in mindfulness concerned he was
already in the directors pocket SL he's
slave to the shadow not to his ego so I
wanted similar people
I wanted actors the talent if they are
stars I'm not averse to the idea of
having stars like for example we had a
star of a different kind not as an actor
but Shekar Kapur the director of
Elizabeth and Bandit Queen has acted in
the film well that's that's because we
are all a group of friends we know each
other and I thought he could act in it
it's like how Mr Attenborough acted in
Jurassic Park or something like that
it's out of a relationship that I called
him to act but otherwise I thought the
film should work around a schedule and
not the schedule around the actors but
it's it's a complicated film anyway so
we didn't want to complicate it any
further
what do you think give someone star
power in India versus America is there
is there a difference in that star power
that it factor
oh my financial is my star come on
laughter so I have great respect but I'm
not going to bring down the technique or
the technician before his altar he left
humbled himself and that's something I
learned while I was a technician
while stars are very important they
could over time be made and what have
you noticed about American stars what
what themes do you see in them aside
from being a talented artist see their
various kinds of stars on what what is
heartening is to know that the great
talent has become a star also that's as
iconic and most of the American stars
that I know have that part that body
called Cochin is it something about
their the way they present themselves to
fans I know for you you've always talked
about you're not about idol worship you
you really wanted to turn a lot of
you're having fan clubs into volunteer
organizations they already are
they have like I have donated my body
probably I was the first actor in India
I don't know where else to donate body
for science and I did it not not to show
off but so that to show away and so that
now there are many body donors in India
and when I say body donor we don't have
to go into the gory details of autopsy
alone you could harvest body parts which
could be useful in in a country but a
lot of poor people can can't afford to
buy body parts transplants and so many
people who have to live to take care of
a family so and this was this signatory
for this donation was my daughter and so
it made a nice impact on my fans and
they have already donated two hundred
thousand I willed living people so there
are two hundred thousand eyes one day
rather which are going to be used for
that that's probably four hundred
thousand people can see what is it about
idol worship that's negative to you and
in terms of being put on a pedestal
we beat
a pistol is good but even in Rome you
had these great warriors walking into we
be feted and there's always an old man
sitting right behind him in the in the
chariot reminding him remember you're
mortal it comes from the time much
before Christ so this I think there's
this little wise and me which keeps
telling me that let's not cheat them
anymore
I mean nothing is worthy of worship
that's my feeling
nothing is worthy of worship it can be
used it can be harnessed can be loved
but that's my feeling and then might
sound like I'm too rational but that's
what I am well there's an American
saying that is um remember the people
that you pass on the way up because they
can be the same that you see on the way
down and that's a it's a reminder of
humility I think yeah but that's one
part that's only about yourself
that since you're gonna go up and down
you better know the steps but what I am
talking about is something else I'm
talking about generally I believe
nothing is worthy of worship it should
be respected it can be venerated it can
be loved that's that's my problem with I
mean daya fication so we understand that
never before has there been another
Tamil film released in so many theaters
in the u.s. how much does it mean to you
it means a lot and because I started as
a child actor then went into a plea and
waited for myself to grow become
something and I never wanted I'm a
reluctant actor I came back to become a
technician I was a dance choreographer I
have stopped learning dance very early I
was dancer systems and a choreographer
then an assistant director then I
co-wrote some scripts all these things
happened before 20 so that's a great
opportunity it's learning and getting
paid and getting
even those but not famous enough if you
compare today but if I was a nobody and
people were so kind to me they sort of
thought that I had it when even I didn't
think I have some kind of a talent
worthy of exhibition but they kept
goading me into going to the and these
were strangers who became friends and
then my brothers and some of them my
father figures yeah my mentor mr. K
Balachander picked me up from nowhere
and gave me a small bit roll and full
number one it's like mr. Danny day-lewis
doing a role in Gandhi you don't even
notice him and then few years later
there's mr. Danny day-lewis it's like
that
I I was a nobody in the phone second
film I had a very important role third I
was promoted to lead man fourth and I
was ready to play any role in his film
sometimes I just walk through in a
character I've done 36 films with it but
my mentor which itself is record well if
I've read correctly I understand you
took a hiatus and came back in 1970
that's correct and that you usually
wanted to be a scientist nobody nobody
wanted me it's it's like I was a child
and no more a child so um and they
wanted a kid and I was not that cute kid
anymore
so I had to wait that long it was 15
years not 15 10 years so I trained all
the while and trained as a dancer in
classical dancing as did a bit of
singing and stuff like that so and I I'm
I'm glad that the industry was kind and
never allowed me to take another hiatus
so was through other people's
encouragement and saying you should
really be up there and working your way
from supporting to then story oh yeah so
many people it's unbelievable that they
are part of my life the part of whatever
a biography of I write they become so
important part of my I mean I can
understand my brother
being with me but these are people came
from nowhere and became part of my life
I truly believe that these are my family
now
so then how did the directorial stance
with be sure will come about because
originally you were just going to star
in the film no it was an idea which I
had this script and I've directed films
before but it it's less work and more
pave and just the star so I was looking
for that I mean having some good time
and getting out of the caravan and
walking do the shot go back sleep read
write forums what I want but that was
not to be because that director was busy
and he had an opinion about the film and
then I said it's my story and it's my
time and I must take over and do it so
the the financial was ready to let me
produce it and sort of someone else so I
got a produce direct act and given - can
you tell us the scene in the film where
once you watched it you were like yes
this is why this is why I'm a filmmaker
and an actor this is it
it's our particular scene there are a
couple of scenes but one scene which is
what the title means that's the cosmic
farm as Misha Roop could be the bigger
the magnified form or the cosmic form
that's what we sure hope means the world
view of things so there's a particular
scene which I would have shot it
slightly more differently if I had all
the equipment available but there are
certain limitations and so we've done
our best and that's one time when I'm
that much more involved in the film
because when I had it cut when I wrote
it I was sure it's gonna be a good scene
but then the logistics of cinema can
always ruin something on the paper but
it didn't happen
pulled it off and that was a scene it's
a warehouse sequence when that came
through sort of came together and I knew
that we were sitting on a good the
position what in cricket language is
called a good wicket did the movie
become what you had first envisioned or
once you got into the editing room it
became its own different story yeah it
always happens in my films especially
but it's sort of sometimes linear
narrative becomes nonlinear for I've
I've done it in a couple of places in
the film but otherwise when I finish the
script I didn't tell anyone the whole
story had to be told and I thought it's
too long to say it as a film so I made
up my mind that I'm gonna make two films
so this is the first film I have already
done 10 percent of the second floor
that's how much I pinned my help on the
script and that's why Barry like the
idea because he he bet on three films
Barry husband a lot of the Rings trilogy
so I think that's the confidence I had
and what I had on paper and a paper
could mean anything it could just be an
artistic dream that everything is
looking beautiful but then I had some
time to mull over it and I didn't tell
anyone I just gave the first piece to
everyone and they liked it and then I
told him I got my crew into confidence
and said I'm gonna make one more would
it be interested and being part of that
and they were and we shot some more
after the main shot was completed and
how do you think American audiences will
respond I think an audience is universal
how how did I respond to American films
as born in a village in South of India
but it worked for me I mean I could
understand Chaplin
with all that knowledge in the language
my linguistic inabilities never came to
the fore when you watch great actors and
even not only Chaplin and at 17 when I
was an assistant director nobody told me
that Citizen Kane is full that the
greatest American film I found it to be
so I discovered Dalton Trumbo on my own
so I think good stuff is international
good stuff is universal and I hope my -
good stuff - well you've mentioned
previously that sometimes audiences are
something to be feared that as a
filmmaker sometimes you're so paranoid
of what the audience will think that you
get out of it yeah that's what I think I
copied that line from Chaplin but that's
not totally my thing Kaplan says it's a
multi-headed monster you don't know how
what it'll think I don't think so
but I think it's that it's a slightly
different replication of myself as an
audience I make films that I really
would love to see and I do it honestly I
think the audience would be my family
and they liked it and because we think
alike and I've realized over time
watching other people what great
filmmakers try to become after they
achieved the greatness is to regain the
naivety of an audience the open mind not
even naivety is not the word the
innocence of the audience without
technique with pearly emotion and they
try to get back into that like how we
think of childhood actors I mean act
directors trying to get back into that
position of an audience which according
to them is the penultimate position to
be the audience when you've achieved
climbed the ladder to the full extent
then what you want to do is reverse the
ladder climb again right so not to judge
well this cut was bad or stark looking
at the edge of the frame
if the camera shakes a bit a filmmaker
notices if if it goes slightly askew he
knows it but a true audience doesn't
care it doesn't care who care whether
the cameras gone Dutch topsy-turvy and
what it's a feeling that they get and
they watch the center of the frame and
sometimes a good director can make them
watch whatever corner of the frame he
wants the audience do that that's when
he truly becomes an audience himself and
he knows what to watch in a frame the
focus shifts automatically the camera
moves towards the subject and the the
audience is so satisfied because that's
exactly what they wanted to see and off
the whole scenario and that's where the
camera goes forward it's a very
satisfying feeling you're mentally
nodding to yourself yeah that's what I
wanted to see and that that's a great
directors work you mentioned in a BBC
interview that you have to be careful
how you spend a lifetime and I'm curious
what advice you would give to another
creative person whether it be a
filmmaker actor dancer who loves the
craft of something but is having trouble
transitioning into making a living from
it and they realize that that may never
happen whether it's due to age or you
know Talent well they always ask me that
if you had not become an actor not
anything in films what would you have
done I said much happier position
without any responsibilities and keep
watching poems because I still do like
watching moving images I'm talking
moving images I'm not saying even films
nor any moving imagery well but it's
National Geographic it's a documentary
and when it's honest it moves me and I
can I could I cannot walk out even from
the stupid film because they capture my
imagination
I probably try to improve that step
silly phone even while it's unraveling
itself in front of me in its full silly
form but I keep repairing it in my mind
so it is an interesting exercise I think
if I had not been influenced and still
be watching them so to somebody who is
an artist was trained but will never
perform that is a tragedy but life is
more important I think it is a tragedy
not perform having practiced so much I
only wish that doesn't happen to too
many people because I think there are
people in in my country I'm sure here
too who are not trained
we're not keen they don't want to be in
this but the money is good so they're
here they don't even care if they're not
emotional or coming to do their work and
they get stuff that a trained man
doesn't get that truly is a tragedy it
happens but I hope it doesn't happen too
many times I think in America it doesn't
happen too often so that's why I like
the star system in America because you
see it Christopher Walken suddenly doing
Deerhunter and suddenly and pennies from
heaven he does a dancer number and he
said Wow he could do that and he didn't
care about showing it in the first full
I mean I man would have known that as an
audience that Richard Gere could dance
or some other actor could sing so well
it's surprising but I'm happy to see
that stars have always been so very well
trained and now nowadays they're getting
more and more training enviable training
we used to hunger for that kind of
experience for preparing myself as an
actor director all the workshops so and
we ibly too many in India in America
you've mentioned too that most actors
are not good
people how did you hone your left brain
side your logical side is that coming
from working on it's not a it's a work
in progress but I think I'm done good
because I'm still making movies and
still driving expensive cars so there
must be some good work done on the left
side too well do you think that that's
the reason many creative people fail and
move home so to speak is because I'm not
great filmmakers who didn't have a
movement to consider themselves moving
away from themselves and realize how
great they are they're stuck in that
room that loneliness that monotonous
sounding television music or loved by
drugs or alcohol they didn't know the
limit and they kill themselves at the
peak of their performing abilities which
happened to few in India - I feel very
bad
sand is that because they let themselves
go - now that because they have not they
then either they believe the press too
much of what's written about them and
truly believe that that's what they are
or they take criticism to the very
extreme and think that they are finished
it's like Chaplin sitting at gold rush
for two weeks saying that I'm right up I
can't do any more and finished but there
was a fantastic crew sitting around him
pampering him there was a lot of money
being wasted
there wasn't a hot producer tracking the
web but it got him through and he went
on for few more years doing what he had
to do that's very important for an actor
somebody has to tell it can't be the
agent it can't be the producer it has to
be him to look into the mirror and feel
happy about what he has achieved and how
much more he can do
by living actress D Wallace said if you
believe the good then you have to
believe the bad oh yes but you believe
but don't keel over to the wrong side
whichever side of this even he keel over
then you go go down and that's I've had
moments many moments of indecision
confusion and suddenly I realized that
there's so many things that I didn't
train well for and then then you sort of
set goals that you can achieve and then
you realize that's the only way to live
a life because if you have a bicycle you
want a motorcycle we have a motorcycle
to go on a car you have a car you want
an airplane to fly and then you're on
and probably a fleet of airplanes there
it could become a owner of airway I mean
there's no end to it but there's some
place you'll have to settle and see that
you don't get into the Peter Principle
everybody reaches their level of
incompetence
you must stop just before them is it
also about managing expectations your
own others yes yes I mean it's
complicated it's very easy to advise
especially you give me a case I'm a
great adviser I don't know how to do it
to myself and and that's applies for
everyone and so so it's a bit of
listening but of disagreeing bit of
agreeing and bit of coming to terms but
what you really are understanding that
this world is so full of talent and you
only one among them it takes a long time
to adjust to that truth especially when
you read good press so but I had the
best there's nobody around like me and
then you have to sit down ruminate and
understand that many have said this
before it's too many what in Indian
cinema teach Hollywood
I think the other word teaches
frightening and because it's most
teachings are disproved after some time
you know you're teaching wrong and
experience tells you that what you've
been taught is wrong so I think if you
can only exchange experiences and
especially you're talking about an
industry and not an individual what
Hollywood can probably pick up there's a
lot that India can pick up from
Hollywood
but what Hollywood could possibly pick
up from India is the total tenacity of
purpose to finish a form as a unit it's
not about unions it's not about people
it's not about the liars
it's not about payments it's not about
dotted lines that's good that can happen
but the whole thing is about the content
and the fashion of a group of people
getting together to get this movie done
even for big folks that's how I wish a
loop was made and it's it's not about
dotted lines
it's not about liars it's not about ugly
finances oh they did exist it's not that
they were but it's the core group work
together and they we're professionals
but they were amateurs when it came to
managing their love for the phone
they just cave and that rarely happens
that happens in underground film or a
group of young full America starting up
but never in established world unless
it's just happening in Hollywood
where big actors lend their time to make
a film of their choice but it's all the
time like that except when there's a
commercial FluMist our wakes up from his
nap comes in sort of what's cold cloth
and his eye wakes up gets does his roll
goes back to sleep or read or have a
good time that also happens
but most other phones down in India are
done with a lot of love because they
wanted official Roop is one of them so
in the reverse what can Hollywood teach
Indian oh lot because we are learning
we're like scheduling budgeting
preparing the actor the actor director
relationship and the discipline and the
set but you can't sacrifice the core a
sense of the love for cinema that's I
always say that I would love to be an
amateur in spite of knowing the craft
because the the etymology of the word
amateur has the inbuilt word mo in it
love it's all about love and that's what
I try to do my phone I have to do this
phone people like Bergman have said that
they I always believe this is my last
film and I may not do another phone
before I've been after so that's the
kind of energy that he used to put in
his phone every phone and I think I took
my cue from there it's a great work to
follow
you've mentioned before that you're a
fan of Orson Welles and I know that he I
believe he had trouble finishing films
sometimes so do you feel that at no cost
something should be finished you're all
about making sure that there's
discipline yeah because it's happened to
me but no fault of mine pictures have
been stopped but I went on and on and
never tired and said I never gave up
there are many people my heroes like
Kurosawa yes he at one time tried to
kill themselves but and that is a
tragedy that the film industry shouldn't
drive an artist to I always feel that
it's very important for the industry to
take care of people like that
it's no use celebrating Dalton Trumbo
after you troubled him through his life
do you think it's the film industry or
that artists
expectations I think generally the world
you celebrate something then it's too
late and when you through in the life
you learn the lesson of how cruel have
been after you see the the result of
your cruelty too late you should have
stopped yourself before I I didn't know
who this is dalton trumbo was i just
liked him and then we went back in
history and found one kind of suffering
and that he had to go through for no
fault of us but America has changed so
the world we understand that she waited
to release the film until the people of
India could have unobstructed access via
the director yes it's an idea which came
to me that's why we also enhanced the
theater experience multiform by bringing
our 3d the sound effect was so good that
you will never get it watching it on a
television screen so on one side I
wanted to keep the ecosystem of the
industry intact not just rush into some
new technology which i think is good for
money and but I think it's also been
proven right in Hollywood like arbitrage
has gone as grassed more through VOD
video on-demand than the theatrical but
that doesn't mean that the theatricals
have gone down it's only that there's
another venue we have discovered to
monetize our phone it's like how we had
only few theatres and we built many
theatres many screens and multiplied
them
I mean met with the demand your supplies
met with the demand and that's what I
was trying to do with DTH there's a
little bit of scuttling but south of
India has understood the vision and
they're staying with me the north is yet
to fully understand
are you finding theaters in the states
that are able to accommodate that
special sound
not America has about 25 to 30 theaters
if I know right I might be wrong but
double down to one state one state in
the whole of the country has 25 theaters
now they'll have 30 by next year and the
sound is incredible when you hear it
you'll understand why I am promoting it
I mean when when I started there were
only two other directors but good enough
predecessors to have that was mr. Lucas
and mr. Spielberg they were working on
the sound when I decided to go on
auro-3d now we understand that there's
been some controversy from Muslim
organizations that are trying to to ban
the film
yeah that's see it's I don't know
because this phone is probably the most
muscle and friendly film I have seen in
recent times it's not not talking about
I have made I've seen and I'm known to
be a man with equipoise I'm not given to
lean to the left all right
I have my own standpoint and I've been
very clear I'm not a politician I've
never gone into the politics of the
situation but I think I have an ethical
duty to take care of my society and I
have a voice which deservingly or not it
is amplified by the work that I do so
I'm very careful in saying what I I say
I would never do a film it's not for the
lack of it it you can't make an animal
house kind of funny story about religion
or in America maybe a Monty Python Life
of Brian may not work well in India and
I'm aware of that
and my thing is I love my people and
India has seen a lot of Hindu Muslim
differences and suffered because of it
and I grieve that tragedy very much I
think both the countries should have
stayed as one we became free instead and
I regret it but Who am I I wasn't even
born when the decision were made but I
so I'm very conscious when I make a fool
not to hurt a larger sentiment or create
a sensation through saying something
nasty but is the duty of the filmmaker
to remind what's happening like you make
a Mississippi Burning
you're not taking the American African
side or the white supremacist side
you're just stating the fact and say
this is what we wear let's not become it
again ever
it's it's a kind of a record that you
find create and wish Europe is not even
that it's it's not a social statement
film it's a it's a thriller which is
realistic it's thrilling it's fast it's
about espionage but it's it's got its
own texture its truth and beauty it's
not a documentary it's not like
Bigelow's film but the grim truth but it
plays it's it's it's around the same
area same team don't you think in
banning it it only makes things bigger I
think I think they have done because my
in one state in India we have 500
theaters
my phone was playing in 500 theatres and
those theaters have already booked out
for a week and a half all of them that's
so but there probably that's what is but
you can't because my feeling is that the
central board of censors they've sat on
the film and they had represent
from the Muslim community and various
other communities and they have watched
the full and thought over it asked me
questions and they left it intact
nothing was removed from the film except
that when we wanted a parent or guidance
kind of certificate because that's also
for business more than anything else
because parents or guidance are those
films are taxed more very strange funny
thing in in my state but they're taxed
more so there but wary of walking into
that territory so I had to ask for a PG
rating not an R as you call it so we got
it and without any damage at all
therefore more of the conduct and once
that is done you can't have small groups
making noises and this is happening in
South Indian it's a it's a group of
southern in Muslims who came a time
they're my people
I mean I have to be kind to them I may
not have a religion but I have love for
people you've never hesitated to state
your opinions and you've just mentioned
that earlier that you you'd like to be
truthful and talk about socially
relevant things what is it that gives
you the willingness to to do that not
all actors are free in that they play
more to politics yes but I think I have
a social responsibility and I can't go
rabble-rousing nor can I keep quiet and
say that what can I do I'm just an actor
I'm not into politics because tomorrow
when there's war I'll have to pitch in
so do I wait for a walk I happen to wait
for riots and then give my comments I'll
talk about it even before they happen
and say please don't do it
I can see things going wrong and you're
not taking even signs and when
something's wrong as done
they must be a wise
hey don't do that it's it's not right
and that's what I do it's simple it's a
very pedestrian reaction it's not a
philosophical highbrow a literary kind
of status need not be given to it it's a
very production
honest reaction to something unethical
dumb immoral I get confused with this
moral issues so I don't know what's
moral and what's immoral keeps changing
over time but ethical we we have to be
kind to each other it's it's it's a
tenet of civil civil society when that
is jeopardized I do react I'm like the
body sensors would tell you pain tip of
the finger tells you that you're going
to be touching fire so somebody has that
I'm like that that's end of the
extremities of society which touches
fire eyes or vice I'll have to inform
the head that something is going wrong
that's what I do do you think that
that's only helped your career because
people respect the fact that you are
willing to see it's done nothing to do
with a career because it doesn't
translate the money it doesn't translate
the money at all probably trouble money
do you think it's easier to be an
independent filmmaker in America rather
than India oh it's very easy to be a
independent filmmaker in India because
all are the very few studios that
outright they've come from the West
one or two Indian companies are doing it
they they are studios the rest are all
independent films it's very easy to be
an independent producer I am an
independent producer not reliant on any
studio facilities but think when things
go wrong it goes drastically wrong for
an independent filmmaker
what do you think the perception is of
independent filmmakers in the States
versus India sounds like it's more
revered in India because there's so many
yeah I know that's the only way we would
rather that we had somebody taking all
the risk for us we're taking it all
ourselves this some of the films don't
even have insurance things go wrong they
go down
it's like bungee jumping we try to check
the cards but it can never be sure it
just seems like there's almost a stigma
sometimes in the United States with
being an independent filmmaker but
somehow people feel that the audience is
not there unless you've been given that
Sundance premiere what would you say
that's why Sundance happened I think
more such things I mean the DTH
revolution might change some of that
that's why attack champion it in a big
way because it's it's access to audience
in the internet was like that but if you
can monetize physically monetize I think
DDH can do it and that's why I look at
it as an opportunity not just for myself
for me it's an allied monetizing venue
another window but for a filmmaker who
wants to be independent different and
intelligent not play all the time by one
rule he has a great for me it's a window
for him it's an open field do you think
independent filmmakers are not as
collaborative as they could be and that
holds them back maybe they're the lone
wolf the rebel that that can't do it in
the group way that you talked about is
necessary to complete a project you
think that hurts them they're
independent oh yes yes it hurts me and
because I bet all the money I have most
of the time if the film doesn't do I
start from scratch again I've done it a
couple of times I don't enjoy it very
much
and you're able to sleep at night oh yes
because to begin with I never had this
money everything else was bonus so I
can't complain you come from a family of
attorneys of law oh yes yeah and so you
were the creative one I know you said
your brother directed yeah I know yeah
they did but I was the first one and it
was not an accident it's by design my
father wanted one artist in the family
and that's why it's so uncanny I was
trained in music classical dancing I
mean boys don't dance very rarely they
do but it's not considered to be the
best thing to do so I danced I sang then
I went then I did a bit of karate and a
martial arts of the South Indian form so
I played the veena which is a string
instrument for a while so my family and
creates me to do all that your advice to
other parents what would you tell them
about if one child seems to be the
creative one but they have hopes to have
him as a doctor or a lawyer that's very
cruel that's bonsai tree here making a
huge tree in putting it into the glass
cage caves that is limited only by your
thinking it's unfair so I say that they
asked me how would you like my daughter
is into acting and it's her choice she
trained in music in America in music
institute that's what you wanted to do
probably she came back and she didn't do
music she did music for one of my phones
and then suddenly became an actress it's
a choice and she has found herself
hopefully she also does music and I
think I should be an agent of argument
in her dreams not I mean I'd be it's all
my life